The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We ended last time
kind of without really a
resolution in the sense that we
looked at this example of
these vendors in India and the
Philippines, and these vendors
were somehow--
they seem to be unable to save
their way out of something
that seems extremely costly
to keep bearing.
They were paying 5% a day, and
even when somebody paid down
their entire debt so that they
didn't have to borrow any
more, they slipped back into
debt within about three weeks.
So it was a sense in which these
people seem to find it
difficult to stay out of debt
and, in particular, to hold
onto their savings.
So here's another experiment,
which sort of brings out some
more off it.
It's in Busia, Kenya, a
letter missing there.
So the way it started
is that--
the experiment is by Esther
Duflo, Michael Kremer, and
John Robinson.
What they had done was they
started by actually giving
farmers some fertilizer.
One of the enduring kind of
puzzles in agricultural and
economics is why farmers in
Africa don't use more
fertilizer given that fertilizer
is something that
basically makes money
for people.
So why don't they use
fertilizer, and their various
possible answers would
talk about those.
But to demonstrate that it
really does seem to work--
what they started by doing is
making sure that it's true
that it works, so what they did
was they had people give
farmers fertilizer and told
them, this is your plot, just
go ahead and use fertilizer,
and they give them free
fertilizer.
So they took a bunch of plots
and gave them free fertilizer.
So very simple, you give people
free fertilizer, they
do use it, not surprisingly,
especially if you make sure
they can't sell it, and
they do use it.
When they use it,
their incomes go
up by 27%, and that's--
Oh, their incomes go
up by 27%, which is
100% increase annually.
So that's like three months,
three months, you bought the
fertilizer, you laid it in the
ground, you waited for three
months, you would get
27% more back.
So they were pretty convinced
that fertilizer was a very
useful thing to use.
And this, they did it many
times, so it varies.
Fertilizer is, in fact,
not predictable.
Sometimes it works better than
others, but the range of these
returns, where you never got
less than 80%, I think,
basically, on your money, and
that's a very good investment
if you get 80% on your money.
Sometimes, you get 500%, but
even if you got a 80% on your
money, that would be
a good investment.
So question is why
don't they do it?
So the various theories,
obviously, on why
people don't do it.
One is that they don't
know about it.
That seems implausible, partly
because fertilizer's not a new
technology.
It's been around for
a very long time.
And second, because take those
farmers who were given free
fertilizer.
They used it, they got 100%
return, annualized return, go
back to those people at the
end of the year and the
beginning of next season and
ask them do you want to use
fertilizer.
98% say yes, of course, we
want to use fertilizer.
Only 37% actually use it.
So these are people who clearly
know fertilizer works
because they did it.
It worked.
There's no two ways about the
fact that they know it
because, the fertilizer, they
had used it, they saw the
results, they saw
it's working.
Why didn't the farmers who had
seen that the fertilizer
generates these massive returns
not go back to using
fertilizer?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Beause they said
couldn't really afford it, and
then also the fact was when
they did have the money,
fertilizer generally
wasn't there.
And when they didn't have
the money it was there.
So it's difficult.
PROFESSOR: OK, so that's
sort of the--
but before we come there,
lets rule out some other
explanations.
So one other explanation is
credit constraint, so we
already discussed it's hard
for the poor to borrow.
Interest rates are very high.
That would be a good explanation
if fertilizer were
indivisible, so if you had to
use a certain minimal amount
to make money.
But fertilizer is extremely
divisible.
You can buy it in like You could
buy 500 grams of it, put
it on a small plot, and
you'll make more money
on that small plot.
If you bought two kilos,
you make more
money on a bigger plot.
If you bought 10 kilos,
you'd have even more.
So the question is why don't
people use fertilizer?
If they have less money,
why don't they use it
on a smaller plot?
It's not enough to say that they
don't have money because
money just--
if you're less money, you
can use it on less land.
The main point is that whenever
you use it, you make
money, so even if you use it on
a smaller plot, the output
on that plot would still go up
by a lot, and the returns
would be 100% a year on
the money you put in.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I understand what
you're saying, but on the
other hand, they can only afford
to fertilize a very
small amount of land, that their
returns might just not
be worth it to make this
tiny investment.
You would have to wait for
several months to get an extra
several rupees whereas you have
this money now, you might
as well spend it now
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I guess that might
be right, but it's sort of--
in the end, it's why aren't they
thinking, look, it's 100
Kenyan shillings now.
I'm going to get 200
in three months.
If it's 100 shillings, and
that's very little, that's a
dollar and a bit, it's still
you get twice as much.
So why aren't people thinking
in proportion?
Why aren't they thinking that
twice as much is a lot more?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't fertilizer
be more viable for bigger
farmers because they have
irrigation, which is required
for fertilizer to really work.
PROFESSOR: Not in
Kenya, actually.
I mean, fertilizer is--
it's true that it would
be more useful.
But mostly even, Kenya
has especially--
this is the what they call
the short rain season.
Most of agriculture in the short
rain season is rain fed,
so I think people don't--
it's true that I'm sure
fertilizer would reduce risk,
but there isn't much of risk.
Even when the rains are not
great, you still make money.
So if you ask farmers, they do
tell you the answer that they
don't have any money.
So they're answer is we
It's exactly what you
said, which is that
they don't have money.
Well, how would we
buy fertilizer?
The fact is that, as you'll see
in a minute, they do have
money, especially when
they harvest.
Farming is a cyclical
business.
You make money at some point.
You plant, you wait for three
months, your crops come out,
you sell your crops,
you get money, then
you wait for a while.
You buy some seeds.
You plant again, so it's
kind of a cycle.
So if you think of the point
when they have sold the crops,
they certainly, at that point,
certainly do have money.
It's not true that they don't,
and we'll see in a minute
evidence that they
do have money.
And in particular,
they seem to--
I mean, even if they can't save
all of it because they
need to eat most of it, they
could have saved a little bit
of it, so they could have
saved the money.
Alternatively, they could just
buy fertilizer then, when they
have the money.
Fertilizer it is very durable.
You just buy fertilizer.
You keep it in a bag.
It'll stay for three months.
It's not that you need to buy
fertilizer on the day when you
need to go farming.
You could have bought fertilizer
ahead of time and
kept it in your home.
So we'll see that they do have
money at some point, and when
they do have money, they
don't necessarily buy
fertilizer with it.
In fact, they did a small
survey, and they asked did you
buy fertilizer at harvest
time when you had money.
The answer is, no, almost
no one did that.
So if you look at the
population, about 30% of them
use fertilizer at any point of
time, but of that 30%, only
about 3% had bought it early
when they had money.
Most of them bought it at the
point of planting, so they had
either managed to save
or they had borrowed.
But in any case, they had--
[INAUDIBLE]
Let me remove Skype.
Yep.
So what is true is that, so
basically, no one buys
fertilizer early even though--
if you think that it's
a problem to--
maybe you don't have money at
planting time, then you should
just buy it early.
So here's a nice experiment,
which is sort of exactly
trying to figure out what's
going on here.
So what they did was they went
to different farmers, and
since some farmers had already
had some experience using
fertilizer and others had not,
they stratified by that.
What does it mean to stratify?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, they're
randomized within the group of
people who had used it before,
and within the group of people
who had used it before.
So they divided up the
population and randomized
within each group, and then they
came to the household and
offered them fertilizer and
said, look, you pay for it.
We will sell it to you, and
we'll bring it to you so you
don't have to go to a
market to buy it.
And that saves a trip, saves
trouble, but it also--
so this was done at harvest
time, and it basically forced
them to make a decision then.
So you couldn't say, well,
maybe I'll buy it.
Maybe I won't.
I'll wait until when
I need it.
It was kind of a all or nothing
decision, where they
had to take a decision right
now when they had money.
This was the first experiment.
Then they follow it up a second
experiment where they
took another set of people,
and then in the second
experiment, they offered people
an additional choice.
You can either choose
when you'll get--
we'll come to sell
you fertilizer.
This was done before harvest, so
they didn't have any money
at that time.
So they said you can either tell
us, and we'll come right
after harvest, or we'll
come when you plant.
Just tell us what to do.
So the first experiment, they
were not given the choice.
They said you want it now, we'll
bring it to you free.
You don't have to go collect.
If not, that's it.
Then you're on your own.
Now, it's you can either
buy now or later.
You're offered a choice.
And the other thing that they
did was other people who were
not given any offer like this,
when it came to the actual
time of the planting, they came
to these people and said
do you want to buy fertilizer.
We'll bring it to you, and then
some people, they offered
a 50% discount.
So they actually said if
we give you a discount,
will you buy it?
So these were the treatments, so
think of the treatments as
the first treatment, all or
nothing at harvest time, you
want to buy fertilizer; second
treatment, before harvest, do
you want to buy fertilizer at
harvest or later; third
treatment, at planting time, do
you want to buy fertilizer
from us if we deliver
it to you free.
That's the experiment.
Before we get into
the experiment,
suppose people were--
what's the disadvantage
of saying that you
can only buy it--
we'll offer it to you
now, but not later?
What's the downside of that?
Why did they go to the second
treatment, do you think, where
they give you a choice
when to buy?
What's the advantage of giving
you this choice?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right, exactly, I
mean, typically we think that
buying things early
is a bad idea.
Why?
Because you're locking
up your money.
I mean, fertilizer's not that
easy to sell, whereas if
somebody got sick, you
had money, you'd
be able to buy medicine.
Now, instead you have
fertilizer.
So why would you
lock up money?
So in general, the standard
intuition would be that
locking up money is a bad
idea, not a good idea.
So in the first treatment,
they were
forced to lock up money.
The second one, they
give them a choice.
So we take the first one,
basically, there was a 50%--
so about, as I said, 25% to 30%
of them use fertilizer.
That went up by 11 to 14
percentage points, so that's
like a 46% to 63% increase
in fertilizer use.
So you get more than 50%, more
than 50% increase in
fertilizer use when you just
tell people, look, we'll bring
it to you for free.
Do you want it at
harvest time?
This did not change--
so then what they looked at is
this season, of course, you
getting it delivered to
you, so you buy it.
It doesn't have any
persistent effect.
You saw that it was
a good idea.
Did you start saving money
or finding a way to
buy ahead of time?
The answer's no.
People seem to be--
when you offer it to them for
free at harvest time, a
substantial number
of them buy it.
But if you said, look, last
year you did this,
look, it was good.
You got much more output.
This time, why don't you
buy on your own?
Just buy it at harvest time.
We won't help you.
You can do it on your own.
Nobody does it.
So it's not the case that
people learn from this
experience to buy fertilizer
to use at harvest time.
They go back to not using
it, basically.
So when you give people a
choice, that's experiment two,
you get bigger effects.
Instead of getting 11 to 14
percentage points, you get 18
percentage points.
That's almost 75% increase in
fertilizer use, so if you give
them a choice, then you get
more people taking it up.
On the other hand, if you show
up at harvest time--
so this is not mainly an effect
of offering it to them,
just bringing it to them.
It's not because they're getting
free transportation.
It's not because they don't have
to go buy it that they're
doing it because if you came to
them at planting time and
said do you want to buy it,
we'll get it to you free, that
has no impact.
If you bring it to people at
planting time free, then they
don't buy it, so it's not the
case that you get the same
effect by just delivering it
to them free at any time.
You have to deliver
it to them free
typically at planting time--
sorry, at harvest time.
When they have money, you have
to deliver it to them free,
then they buy it.
If you bring it to them when
they are planting, and you
offer free delivery, that
doesn't have the same impact.
So it's not that whenever
you offer it to them
free, they buy a lot.
They only buy a lot if
you offer it free
when they have money.
The 50% discount does have a
significant effect, maybe not
surprisingly.
On the other hand, it's not
really smaller than just
offering people to get free
delivery with no discount.
No discount is better than
giving people a discount if
you give them the discount
at the right time--
sorry, the free--
the delivery at the
right time.
So if I go to you at harvest
time, and I say I won't give
you a discount, when do you
want it, you get a bigger
effect than if I tell you I'll
give you 50% discount, but
that I offer that to you
only at planting time.
So just those magnitudes are
what's worth looking at
because you're getting
people--
it's not that people, even if
you offer them a 50% discount,
you don't get as big an effect
as just finding the right time
to make an offer without
a discount.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do people get this
if it wasn't delivered?
PROFESSOR: You just go to the
local town and you buy--
AUDIENCE: --drag it back
or pull it back--
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
bring it on a--
they have all these three-wheel
taxis and little
trucks in Kenya.
You put it in the back of
one, and you bring it.
It's like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, it's a small
cost, actually.
That's the usual.
Now, you notice that
there was this 18
percentage point increase.
That came from a bunch of those
people said, look, it's
free delivery, but
we just want it
delivered at planting time.
So some people behaved as if
they had no worries about
having the money later, and the
other half said bring it
to us now, so a bunch
of people said
bring it to us now.
The reason why this one gives
you a bigger effect than
forcing people to buy early is
because a bunch of those
people actually prefer
to get it late.
So it's clear that the economics
we described before
is working for some people, but
it's also striking that
about half of those people
say, no, we want it now.
We want to lock up our money.
We want our money to
not be spendable.
We want it in fertilizer now.
So what's quite striking is
that people are willing to
lock up their money,
even though it's--
So what could be going on?
So here's a story that
seems to mostly work.
So these people have money
at harvest time and want
fertilizer, but somehow, they
don't manage to buy
fertilizer.
So the reason why the experiment
works is that these
people basically say, look,
we will buy fertilizer.
So what seems to be going on
is that, as we said, 98% of
those people who had plots where
fertilizer was used said
they wanted to buy it again.
Only 37% actually did.
So at harvest time, it seems
most people plan to use
fertilizer, and then only
a small fraction of them
actually managed to get there.
So what seems to happen
is that they
don't manage to implement.
So they think that they're going
to buy fertilizer, but
then somehow end up spending the
money before they get to
the fertilizer.
So one way to think about what
could be happening is that
people say, look, today I really
want to buy fertilizer,
but right now, I really like a
drink or I'd really like to
have a barbecue.
So they go to the market, they
buy something, and they say,
look, it doesn't really matter
because tomorrow,
I'm going to save.
Today, let me have a barbecue,
but tomorrow, I'm definitely
going to save.
So they say that so it doesn't
really matter.
It's going to be in three months
that we're going to
plant, so even if I don't save
today, I'll save tomorrow.
So sometimes, this is
represented by this formula.
These kind of preferences are
sometimes [INAUDIBLE]
by this formula.
So the U function is the
utility you get or the
pleasure you get out
of eating today or
tomorrow or day after.
Today is c0, tomorrow's c1, day
after is c2, the day after
that is c3.
Or we could think of months,
c0 this month, c1 is next
month, et cetera.
What's important is that U of
c1 is multiplied by two
numbers, both less than 1.
U of c2 is multiplied by
beta delta squared.
If delta's less than 1, delta
squared is less than 1, but I
didn't multiply by beta
squared delta squared.
I multiplied by beta
delta squared.
The day after that is multiplied
by beta delta
cubed, so I didn't multiply
by beta cubed delta cubed.
Why am I doing that?
What's the point being made
by having that structure?
This is sometimes called a
quasi hyperbolic model.
Why did I put that
structure there?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe like delta is
something that [INAUDIBLE]
whereas beta is a variable that
probably won't happen.
Like, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, specifically,
these are constant, so think
of them as being numbers.
Beta's like a number, like--
maybe delta is 0.9, and beta's
something like 0.6.
That's the sort of numbers
people often throw
around over a month.
What does this preference
specifically say?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Seems like it's just
saying that if more importance
is given to c0, and anything
in the future as a discount
factor of beta.
But the further into the future
you go, you go from
delta to delta squared
so [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, but
specifically what it's saying
is that today versus tomorrow
is very different from
tomorrow versus day
after or day after
versus day after that.
It's saying specifically that
when I offer you a choice
between today and tomorrow,
you want it today, but you
don't care as much about day
after versus day after that.
So beta and delta both numbers
less than 1, then what this
preference is exactly
saying is that I
would take one today.
I'll give up two tomorrow to
get one today, but when I
compare tomorrow with day after,
I'm not going to take
one tomorrow instead
of two day after.
So people are very short--
they want things now, but they
don't really care about when
they get it if they
don't get it now.
Why is that an interesting
set of preferences?
Well, if you believe those set
of preferences, then this
behavior seems to start
to make sense.
So what I really want
is I want tomorrow--
since I don't care about whether
I consume tomorrow or
day after, I want tomorrow
to do the saving.
Today, I don't want to save
because today is much more
important to me than tomorrow.
Tomorrow is not that much more
important than day after, so
if I want some money for day
after, the best way to get
there is by eating a lot today,
saving a lot tomorrow,
and then ending up with
the money day after.
I would rather do that than eat
little today and also a
little tomorrow.
I would rather save by binging
today and then waiting, and
then implementing
saving tomorrow.
The problem is that when
you get around to
tomorrow, what happens?
If your plan is I will save more
tomorrow, I'll eat more
today, save more tomorrow,
what's the
problem with that plan?
AUDIENCE: Tomorrow
becomes today.
PROFESSOR: Tomorrow
Once tomorrow becomes today, you
start thinking, OK, well,
I have the same preferences.
c0 then becomes tomorrow's c0.
I want to implement the
same plan tomorrow.
I want to eat a lot tomorrow,
and get day after to do the
savings, and you can
keep doing that.
That's the problem.
OK, so that's the idea.
Now do people actually
behave in such a way?
So here's an experiment.
Ashraf, Karlan, and Win asked
1,700 subjects in the
Philippines the following
questions.
So they asked them, first, would
you prefer 200 pesos now
or 250 pesos later?
Some people said I'd prefer
250 later, in
which case, they stopped.
If they said that they would
prefer 200 now rather than 250
in a month, then they were
asked how about 300?
If they said they'll even take
300, then they were asked how
much would it take to stop you
from wanting 200 today?
Somebody might say 400.
I'll take 200 today
and 400 a month.
So there are people who could
say 250 I'll take in a month.
Some people say I'll take
300 in a month.
Some people will say
name a number.
So do you see how it goes?
Then they are given a break.
They went and wander around,
then came back, and 15 minutes
later, they were asked the same
set of questions, but
with one change, which is that
instead of asking them about
today versus in a month, they
were asked in six months
versus in seven months.
Same thing, but notice
what we're doing is
exactly this exercise.
We are exactly trying to
pinpoint whether or not people
have a different view of today
versus tomorrow versus one
month later at any other
point of time.
That's exactly the idea, that
am I someone who thinks that
tomorrow is going to be--
do I think that tomorrow
it's going to be it
really doesn't matter.
I can cut back tomorrow,
but I really don't
want to cut back today.
So this is what they found.
This is a complicated
table, but we can
go through it slowly.
So the way to think about
it is that the--
each square in a matrix is how
much money would you take
today versus 200--
so how much money in the future
versus 200 today.
Along the vertical dimension,
we're increasing the amount of
money in a month from today.
On the horizontal dimension,
we increasing the amount of
money in a month from
six months.
And those are the fraction of
people who make those choices.
So some people are
just patient.
Those people say, you offer
me 200 today, I'll
take 250 in a month.
You offer me 200 in six
months, I'll take
250 in seven months.
Some people say you offer
me 200 today, I
take 250 in a month--
or more than 250, but less than
300 in a month, and they
express the same preference
in the future as well.
But then interesting people
are the people who seem to
have different preferences, and
we see that there are both
kinds of people.
There are some people
who are--
So what is the dark squares?
What are the dark squares
telling you?
Who are those people?
The really dark ones.
What are their preferences?
AUDIENCE: They'll take less
money, one month from now then
require more money
in the future.
PROFESSOR: The really daft, daft
ones are the ones who are
saying I'll take less than 250
for 200 in one month, but six
months or seven months, it'll
take me more than 250 to
compensate.
So they seem to be the opposite
of the kind of people
who you're talking about.
They seem to be impatient
in the future but
patient in the present.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: All right,
I have a question.
Could it be that it's not so
much about money today versus
money tomorrow, and preferences
for consumption
versus investment?
So if you're waiting for the 250
in a month, you're putting
your income towards investment
as opposed to [INAUDIBLE]
consumption.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Does that
make sense?
PROFESSOR: I mean,
it makes sense.
It's just I don't understand
why that's different.
It's the same thing.
I'm going to get money
in the future.
Investment is just a way to
get money in the future.
I think it's the same thing.
What's not visible, but I can
tell you, is that those three
dark squares, which are people
who are patient now but
impatient in the future--
that's about 15% of the
population seem to be patient
now, impatient in the future.
Now, the ones who are in the
kind of what I call hyperbolic
squares, that's about 25% of
the population, they're
impatient now, patient later.
They are the people
who are impatient.
They're saying I'll take 200
now over 300 later, but--
or was it 250 later?
But in a month, I'll reverse
that preferences.
I'll take 200 in six
months rather than
250 in seven months.
Sorry, the other way.
I'll take 250 in seven months,
but 200 in six months, and
that's about 25% of
the population.
And then there is another 17%
of the population who are in
that other box, and they're
people for whom--
about half of those are actually
more patient now than
they were in the future than
the other way around.
So basically, what this
shows is that it's not
everybody's like that.
Some people are just
very impatient.
Who are the very impatient
people?
Which box would they be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Those people, we--
You're right, they are
the people who are--
I guess they're the people who
are most impatient, but some
of those people are more
impatient now.
Some people are more impatient
in the future.
Who are the most
patient people?
Which box?
AUDIENCE: Require 250
now or later?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the top
left-hand boxes were the most
patient people.
So basically, what this says
there's about a third of the
population who are
very patient.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What were
the incomes of the
people in this survey?
Like is 250 a lot for them,
relative to 300 or--
PROFESSOR: No, these
are actually
small amounts of money.
Not very cvalued.
These are not very big
amounts of money.
AUDIENCE: But in terms of part
of their income, would that be
significant or not?
PROFESSOR: Significant per
billion, but really not.
So the point that we want to
take away from this is that
people seem to vary a lot.
It's not that there's one kind
of people in the world.
Some people are patient now and
impatient in the future.
A lot more people are impatient
now and patient in
the future.
But there's a whole bunch of
people who are both impatient
now and impatient in the future,
and a whole bunch of
people who are patient now and
patient in the future.
So there are all kinds
of different
behaviors in this table.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this table change
for people in developed
countries who are making
lots of money?
PROFESSOR: So here's
another experiment.
It's not here.
Let's look at another one.
This is actually interesting.
I think I have it here.
I'll show it to you.
Actually not--
it's quite interesting.
This one was done in the
US, and it's kind of
interesting to see.
[INAUDIBLE], OK, good.
It is something funny.
This is not going to get
recorded, but it's this--
yeah.
So this is a very famous
experiment on the US.
Exactly the same kind
of question, but
now, people were asked--
so this is the median
response.
So people were asked how much
money would you take in x
months, where x is either three
months, one year, or
three years, relative to
that much money today.
OK, so this is in the US with
college students, and then
these were Cornell students
if I remember right.
So you can see, this
is the answer--
it's interesting.
So if I offer you $15 today
versus $30 in three months,
the median response--
many people were asked this
question, and this is the
answer to the question, what's
the median response.
So if you take half
the people--
so for example, for $15, half
the people said I'll take less
than $30, half the people said
I'll take more than $30, so
the median response was $30.
So you can see that, basically,
the US in three
months, the trade off
is basically people
want twice the money.
That's a yearly discount
factor of 277%.
For one year, they say $60.
For three years,
they say $100.
Now, the point is that that
number is getting, relatively,
you're getting more patient as
you look into the future.
So it's today versus the future
always, but as I may
force you to look further into
the future, you become
actually more patient.
And that sort of phenomenon I
was alluding to, which is that
as people really want it today,
but the difference
between tomorrow and in
one year later is
not that much more.
AUDIENCE: So the amount
increase, right?
It's not [INAUDIBLE]
more patient just because you
are talking about $3,000
versus $15.
Then you say [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so that's
exactly right.
That's to make the other
point, that as amounts
increase, people look like
they're more patient.
So if this was a lot of money--
so in the US, they're
going to look actually more
impatient than in the
Philippines.
The Philippines, they were
looking much more patient
because these were actually big
amounts of money in the
Philippines.
In the US, for those
amounts of money,
they look more impatient.
So it's when the amounts of
money are bigger, people seem
to look more patient.
That's the bottom
line of that.
The bottom of that says that
once you go to $3,000, people
really don't want
twice as much.
They'll take much less than
twice as much to wait three
months, so people get much more
patient as you increase
the amount of money.
I think that's a very kind
of interesting fact.
I need to go back to where
I was, but this is a--
so that's kind of the answer to
your question, is that this
is actually relatively--
people are actually-- no,
this is the wrong--
I need to go back to the PDF.
So actually, they are relatively
patient here
because these are amounts of
money that are relatively
large for them.
If you make the amount of money
smaller, people become
less patient, not
more patient.
So in the US, with these
choices, they look more
impatient actually, not
less impatient.
OK, so the question is can this
is really explain the
fertilizer puzzle?
So we can see that there are
people, about a quarter of the
population, do behave
in this funny way.
They want it now, and they think
in the future they're
going to be very patient,
so they want to
postpone their savings.
They want to say I will consume
now and save later.
That's a kind of a natural
instinct for about a quarter
of the population.
The problem is that this
requires people
to be pretty naive.
What do I mean by naive?
I mean they need to actually not
realize that this is what
they're doing because otherwise
they should be able
to say, look, but I'll do that
tomorrow as well, and day
after and the day after that, so
I'll never buy fertilizer.
I want to buy fertilizer.
So if you were sophisticated
and, you fully understood what
you were doing, what
would you do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You force yourself
to save [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You'll buy now.
You just buy now.
You know that you can
never really--
Yeah, or you save now, whatever
you need to do.
You know that you'll never win
the game by postponing because
you know tomorrow you'll
have the same problem.
So basically, if you're
sophisticated,
you would buy now.
So you never want to do it, so
you really need people to be
pretty naive to be able to--
In other words, sophisticated
people should not react to
this program.
They would buy in any case.
The only advantage this program
offers is that they're
getting free delivery, but free
delivery, as we saw, is
not worth that much.
When you give people just free
delivery, that doesn't have a
big effect.
So in other words, if these guys
are really sophisticated,
they shouldn't need this program
to get them to buy
fertilizer.
They would buy it in any case
because they'll realize that
this is what's going on and
say, look, if I can try to
fool myself and say I'm going
to buy it tomorrow, but I'm
not going to buy it tomorrow.
I'm always going to
do the same thing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Didn't they say that
the fertilizer wasn't
available [INAUDIBLE]
back to the city to check
it, so that's why they
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm sure that's also
true, but just take this
particular experiment.
I'm sure there are other costs,
like there is some
transportation costs of finding
fertilizer, et cetera,
but it's hard to imagine that's
the only problem.
However, here's a problem with
saying that they are
sophisticated.
Suppose people were
sophisticated, then they
wouldn't want the fertilizer--
the program would not have an
effect because, basically,
they would buy it in any case.
Now, suppose they're not
sophisticated, so they don't
understand they do this.
Suppose they come and tell you
do you want to buy now or in
the future?
What would you say?
You all would say in the future
because why would
[INAUDIBLE]?
I don't realize I'm going to
do this, so then I have no
reason to say lock
up my money.
I should always ask to spend
it in the future.
You cannot have them being
completely fully
sophisticated, in which case the
program would not have an
effect, because they're
sophisticated.
They don't need the program.
They'll buy in any case.
But if you assume that they was
not sophisticated at all,
then they would say,
look, bring it
back at planting time.
I'll buy it then.
Why would I lockup my money?
Because I don't understand
that I have this problem.
So these people must be
halfway between being
sophisticated and not
being sophisticated.
They cannot be either
fully sophisticated.
If they were fully
sophisticated, they would not
need this program.
If they were fully
unsophisticated, they would
not respond to when you offer
them and ask them do you want
to buy it now or later, they
would all say later, and half
of them say they want it now
even though they don't need
the fertilizer now.
So some of those people must
realize that later, they're
going to not have the money,
so somehow there is some
combination of sophistication
and naivete that's driving
this behavior.
So one way to look at this
question of how sophisticated
is go back to that experiment
that we were talking about,
the Ashraf, Karlan, and Yin.
What they do is they offer their
subjects a lock-box.
A lock-box is just a box where
the key is usually kept with
someone else, so you don't
have access to the key.
You can put money into it.
It's just a money box.
And they were told that
you can set you goal.
Your goal can be either a date,
so I'll break the box,
I'll open the box
at Christmas.
Or it could be an
amount of money.
I'll open the box once
I have $200 in it.
So if you look at what people
say, most people want it on a
date, so a huge fraction say
I want it on Christmas, my
wife's birthday, my husband's
birthday, my son's birthday,
my child's graduation,
something like that.
Then some people have an
amount based goal.
They say that I need it for
buying a house, so I need this
much money.
But most people seemed to
set time-based goals.
Now, out of 1,7000 people,
only 200 people
wanted these boxes.
So not everybody wanted it.
In fact, only one out of eight,
roughly, wanted one of
these boxes.
But among those who did, there's
a massive effect of
being hyperbolic.
Hyperbolic are those people who
are patient in the future
but impatient now.
Those are the people who really
wanted the lock-boxes,
so that's what you'd expect.
You'd expect that somebody who
is fundamentally patient, but
is impatient right now, is the
one who wants a lock-box
because they do see the
value of saving.
They're patient fundamentally,
but they're impatient right
now in the moment.
Those are the people who would
want a lock-box, and that's
exactly what you find.
You find that the people who
want the lock-box tend to be
people who are patient in
general, in the future are
patient, but are less
patient right now.
They want the lock-box to kind
of bind their hands.
So they seem to know that
they're hyperbolic, so a lot
of these people seem to know
they're hyperbolic.
They seem to realize that they
have this problem, so they're
not unsophisticated.
They seem to be relatively aware
of their-- they're not,
at least, totally
unsophisticated.
They seem to have some
awareness of their
self-control problem.
The other striking thing is
only women are effected.
Men don't seem to understand
they have this problem, even
though they do, actually.
So women seem to understand
they have a problem.
Men also have the same problem,
but they don't seem
to understand it.
Now, here's another experiment,
last experiment we
will talk about, which gives a
different take to this men
versus women question.
We've been talking a lot about
this kind of hyperbolic view,
which says that I'm worried that
I won't be able to save.
An alternative view of why
people don't save is they feel
like I want to save, but I
know that I can't because
somebody else will come and
take the money away.
My husband will spend it, or my
brother will come and beg
me money, and I'll have to give
it to him or something.
So one other reason for not
saving, which is related, and
one reason why women might want
a lock-box more might not
be because just that
they're hyperbolic.
They might also worry about the
fact that their husbands
will just take away the money,
and that might explain their
demand for lock-boxes, that they
want to keep the money
away from their husband and say
that we can't get at the
money right now.
So this is an experiment
in a bank.
This one was done by Simone
Schaner, who was a
PhD Student at MIT.
So this is a bank, and
basically, she invited a bunch
of married couples to the bank
and said do you want to open
an account.
And the accounts she offered
had came in three types.
I mean, everybody was offered
one joint account for two
spouses, one wife's account,
and one husband's account.
The reason why they did that,
she was trying to get at this
idea that maybe if I have a
joint account with my husband,
that's not very good because
he can take out the money.
If I want to have an account,
I want full control of it.
So what she's interested in is
this question, are people
sufficiently aware of this
problem that they're willing
to give up a high return
account to
have their own account?
So the design of the experiment
is one where,
sometimes, randomly, the joint
account has the highest
interest rate, and your own
account has a very low
interest rate.
And what she's interested in is
whether you would give up
getting a high interest
rate account to
get your own account.
So for the whole family, it
would be better to get a joint
account in terms of returns.
So the returns can vary between
0% to 10%, so you
could be getting 10% on the
account instead of zero, but
you might choose zero because
you don't want your wife or
husband to get at it.
So I'll skip this.
This just explain the point.
The point is that people got
different accounts offered, so
some people were offered a
joint account with the
interest rate zero, a man's
account with interest rate
zero, but a joint account
with interest rate two.
So this is sort of just to
understand the experiment, you
might be someone who gets the
joint account interest rates
could be 10, but the man's
account interest rate could be
zero, and the woman's account
interest rate could be two.
So what's in the squares are
the excess interest rate on
the account you're choosing, so
maybe you choose an account
which gives you 4%.
You could have gotten the best
account you could have got
would have interest
rate of 10.
Your excess interest rate is
negative in that case.
You are getting a -6%
on the interest.
So the question here, the reason
why this experiment is
interesting, you're trying to
figure out do people give up
getting lots of extra money
to make sure that somebody
doesn't have access
to their account.
So first thing she did
was to figure out--
she'll administer
these questions
where they ask them--
it's kind of like the questions
we were asking.
How much money would you give
up today for 290 Kenyan
shillings tomorrow?
So these are questions basically
aimed to measure how
impatient people.
Would you take 20 today or 200
tomorrow, and if you say 20
today, you're very impatient,
obviously.
So that's the kind of question
she was asking.
So what she did, by using that,
what she figured out was
who are the couples who
are well matched.
So if I'm impatient and my wife
is impatient, that's no
problem because neither
of us want to save.
So I don't have to tie my
husband's hands or my wife's
hands because I have the same
preferences as she does, and
therefore, if she wants to
spend, I also want to spend.
Then there are couple which are
both parties are patient,
so if one wants to save, the
other wants to save.
And then there are people
who were given--
the couples which
are ill matched.
Ill matched couples are where
one says I want to save now,
the other says I want
to spend now.
So they're ill matched
couples.
Now, it's the ill matched
couples that are going to
choose accounts that
have low returns.
If you're well matched, it
really doesn't matter who's
name the account is in because
we have the same objectives.
We both want to spend now.
We both want to spend
in the future.
Whatever we want to do,
we both want to do.
But if one of the spouses is
patient, and the other's
impatient, you have a problem.
Now, it turns out, she went
with the hypothesis that
she'll find that only the
men are impatient.
Turns out it was about 50/50,
about men and women are
equally likely to be less
patient than their spouse.
But a lot of these households
were ill matched, so a lot of
the households had one spouse
who was very patient and the
other spouse who was
very impatient.
That's a setting where you'd
imagine going back to the
issue we were raising, as we
said, maybe people don't save
because they feel that
they can't save.
If they try to save, the spouse
will just spend it.
So if one of the spouses is
patient, but the other's
impatient, the impatient
spouse kind of has an
advantage because once the
money's spent, it's gone.
The patient spouse will keep
guarding the money, but the
impatient spouse, all she has
to do is to spend it.
Once it's spent, it's gone, so
in a sense, the impatience
spouse always has
an advantage.
So you're always fighting
against the impatience spouse.
The patient spouse is always
trying to save it and can't do
much about it once the
money's spent.
But as a patient spouse
is always--
if she's saved it through today,
she has to save it
through tomorrow.
In some sense, it's kind of
an asymmetric problem.
So what she's looking for is
what happens to these ill
matched couples.
So this is sort of just to give
a sense of how many are
ill matched.
Yeah, Melissa?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: We'll be done
in two minutes.
So this is a graph of
ill matched couples.
A lot of these are at zero.
You can see zero means you have
the same discount factor.
You're equally patient.
But you can see that there are
people who are difference of
-0.5, so that means
that I want it--
my discount factor is maybe
0.9, and my spouse is 0.4.
And look, it's basically
symmetrical.
Men and women are
not different.
It's just one of the
spouses is more
impatient than the other.
And then what she looks at--
I'll skip these and show
you the picture.
So on the horizontal axis
is excess interest rate.
How much are you giving up?
When the wife's account has,
let's say, the highest
interest rate over the
other account--
what fraction of the people
use the account more?
And you can see that basically,
for well matched
couples, the shared saving in
that account is clearly
increasing with interest rate.
If the interest rate
is higher, you save
more in that account.
For ill matched couples, they
see no relationship.
You don't save more because the
account is more rewarding.
Why?
Because it doesn't matter if
it's more rewarding or not.
You just don't want that on
the other guy to have that
access to that account.
So ill matched couples don't
react to the interest rate.
Their priority is
something else.
They want their own account.
Doesn't matter whether that's
a low interest account.
The well matched couples, you
see this, and you can see the
same thing for the
joint accounts.
The joint accounts, again, it's
the same question, excess
interest rate, share saving.
The well matched couples, as the
interest rate goes up, you
save more in that account.
In the badly matched couples,
it doesn't matter.
Interest rate doesn't matter.
If you're badly matched, you
choose the one that you will
keep the other guy out.
You're not the one that has
the highest interest rate.